spoiler alert ahead the force awakens
likely marks the final chapter of
Harrison Ford's a Star Wars journey ET
was exclusively with episode 7 star
Daisy Ridley you've talked about
Harrison Ford last day on set but now
that we kind of know it was really his
last day on set what was that day like I
remember going in the day that him and
Adam were doing that scene and there was
like a real like somberness in the air
it was very strange and poignant but the
last day he made a great speech and it
was really nice because he is great as
Beatrice yeah and he put into words what
all of us were thinking like there was
just a huge amount of appreciation and I
think he was I'd obviously don't to
speak for him but I think he enjoyed it
maybe not more than he thought he would
be it was just so enjoyable the whole
thing and I think that took people by
surprise like how wonderful it was you
can relive your favorite moments with
Han Solo when the force awakens comes to
blu-ray April 5th